En 2011, durant les six derniers mois de la vie de Kim Jong-Il,
j'ai vécu clandestinement en Corée du Nord.
Je suis née et j'ai grandi en Corée du Sud, son ennemi.
Je vis en Amérique, son autre ennemi.
Depuis 2002, j'avais plusieurs fois visité la Corée du Nord.
Et j'en étais venue à la conclusion que, pour écrire dessus avec sens,
ou pour comprendre l'endroit au-delà de la propagande du régime,
la seule option était l'immersion totale.
Alors je me suis faite passer pour une enseignante et une missionnaire
dans une université pour garçons de Pyongyang.
L'université de science et de technologie de Pyongyang
a été créée par les chrétiens évangélistes qui coopèrent avec le régime
pour éduquer les fils de l'élite nord-coréenne,
sans prosélytisme, qui est un crime capital là-bas.
Les étudiants étaient 270 jeunes hommes,
qui devaient devenir les futurs dirigeants
de la dictature la plus isolée et la plus brutale qui soit.
Lorsque je suis arrivée, ils devinrent mes étudiants.
2011 était une année particulière,
marquant le 100e anniversaire de la naissance
du Grand Leader originel de la Corée du Nord,
Kim Il-Sung.
Pour célébrer l'occasion, le régime avait fermé toutes les universités,
et avait envoyé les étudiants dans les champs
pour construire l'idéal tant proclamé de la RPDC,
une nation la plus prospère et la plus puissante au monde.
Mes étudiants furent les seuls épargnés.
La Corée du Nord est un goulag se faisant passer pour une nation.
Tout ici se rapporte au Grand Leader.
Chaque livre, chaque article de journal, chaque chanson, chaque émission télévisée,
il n'y a qu'un seul sujet.
Les fleurs portent son nom,
ses slogans sont gravés dans les montagnes.
Chaque citoyen porte à tout moment le badge du Grand Leader.
Même leur calendrier commence avec la naissance de Kim Il-Sung.
L'école était une prison étroitement gardée, se faisant passer pour un campus.
Les enseignants ne pouvaient partir en sortie collective
qu'accompagnés d'un gardien officiel.
Même là, nos excursions étaient limitées aux monuments nationaux consacrés
à la gloire du Grand Leader.
Les étudiants n'étaient pas autorisés à quitter le campus,
ou à communiquer avec leurs parents.
Leurs journées étaient méticuleusement organisées,
et tout leur temps libre
était dévoué à honorer leur Grand Leader.
Les plans de leçons devaient être approuvés par l'équipe nord-coréenne,
chaque classe était enregistrée et faisait l'objet d'un rapport,
chaque salle était sur écoute,
et chaque conversation, interceptée.
Chaque espace blanc était couvert des portraits
de Kim Il-Sung et Kim Jong-Il,
comme partout ailleurs en Corée du Nord.
Nous n'étions jamais autorisés à parler du monde extérieur.
En tant qu'étudiants en science et technologie,
beaucoup d'entre eux étaient diplômés en informatique
mais ils ignoraient l'existence de l'Internet.
Ils n'avaient jamais entendu parler de Mark Zuckerberg ou de Steve Jobs.
Facebook, Twitter — rien de tout ça n'aurait signifié quoi que ce soit.
Et je ne pouvais pas leur dire.
J'étais allée là-bas pour chercher la vérité.
Mais par où commencer lorsque l'idéologie d'une nation entière,
la réalité quotidienne de mes étudiants,
et même mon propre poste à l'université,
avaient toutes été construites sur des mensonges ?
J'ai commencé avec un jeu.
Nous avons joué à « Vérité et Mensonge ».
Un volontaire écrivait une phrase sur le tableau,
et les autres étudiants devaient deviner
si c'était la vérité ou un mensonge.
Une fois, un étudiant a écrit :
« Je suis allé en vacances en Chine l'an dernier »,
et tout le monde a crié : « Mensonge ! »
Ils savaient tous que ce n'était pas possible.
Quasiment aucun Nord-Coréen n'est autorisé à quitter le pays.
Même voyager au sein de leur pays nécessite un laisser-passer.
J'avais espéré que ce jeu révélerait la vérité à propos de mes étudiants,
parce qu'ils mentent si souvent et si facilement,
que ce soit sur les accomplissements mythiques de leur Grand Leader,
ou l'affirmation étrange qu'ils avaient cloné un lapin en CM2.
La différence entre la vérité et les mensonges
leur semblait floue par moments.
J'ai mis du temps à comprendre les différents types de mensonge ;
ils mentent pour protéger leur système contre le monde,
ou ces mensonges leur ont été enseignés,
et ils les régurgitent simplement.
Ou, par moments, ils mentent par habitude.
Mais si tout ce qu'ils ont connu, ce sont des mensonges,
comment s'attendre à ce qu'ils soient différents ?
Ensuite, j'ai essayé de leur apprendre la dissertation.
Mais ça s'est avéré pratiquement impossible.
Les dissertations requièrent d'établir sa propre thèse
et d'utiliser un argument factuel pour la prouver.
On avait toutefois simplement dit à ces étudiants quoi penser,
et ils obéissaient.
Dans leur monde, l’esprit critique n'était pas autorisé.
Je leur ai aussi donné un devoir hebdomadaire
consistant à écrire une lettre personnelle, à n'importe qui.
Ça a pris du temps, mais à la fin, certains d'entre eux ont commencé à écrire
à leurs mères, à leurs amis, à leurs petites amies.
Bien que ces lettres n'étaient que des devoirs,
et qu'elles ne parviendraient jamais aux destinataires visés,
mes étudiants commencèrent lentement à y révéler leurs sentiments véritables.
Ils écrivaient qu'ils étaient fatigués de la similarité présente partout.
Ils s'inquiétaient pour leur avenir.
Dans ces lettres, ils ne mentionnaient que rarement leur Grand Leader.
Je passais tout mon temps avec ces jeunes hommes.
Nous mangions tous ensemble, nous jouions au basket ensemble.
Je les appelais souvent gentlemen, ce qui les faisait rigoler.
Ils rougissaient à l'évocation des filles.
Et je suis venue à les adorer.
Les voir s'ouvrir, même de la plus petite façon,
était profondément émouvant.
Mais quelque chose aussi n'allait pas.
Durant ces mois à vivre dans leur monde,
je me suis souvent demandée si la vérité, en fait, améliorerait leurs vies.
Je voulais tant leur dire la vérité,
sur leur pays et sur le monde extérieur,
où la jeunesse arabe renversait son régime pourri,
utilisant le pouvoir des réseaux sociaux,
où tout le monde, à part eux,
était connecté à travers cette toile mondiale,
qui n'était pas mondiale finalement.
Mais pour eux, la vérité était dangereuse.
En les encourageant à la poursuivre, je les mettais en danger —
de persécution,
de déchirement.
Lorsqu'il est interdit d'exprimer quoi que ce soit en public,
on devient bon à lire les non-dits.
Dans l'une de leurs lettres à mon intention,
un étudiant a écrit qu'il comprenait
pourquoi je les appelais tout le temps gentlemen.
C'était parce que je leur souhaitais d'être gentil dans la vie, il a dit.
Lors de mon dernier jour, en décembre 2011,
le jour de l'annonce de la mort de Kim Jong-Il,
leur monde a volé en éclats.
Je devais partir sans dire adieu.
Mais je crois qu'ils savaient combien j'étais triste pour eux.
Une fois, vers la fin de mon séjour, un étudiant m'a dit :
« Professeur, nous ne pensons jamais à vous comme étant différente de nous.
Nos circonstances sont différentes, mais vous êtes pareille que nous.
Nous voulons que vous sachiez que nous pensons à vous comme étant pareille. »
Aujourd'hui, si je pouvais répondre à mes étudiants avec ma propre lettre,
ce qui est bien sûr impossible,
je leur dirais ceci :
« Mes chers gentlemen,
ça fait un peu plus de trois ans depuis que je vous ai vus.
Maintenant, vous devez avoir 22 ans — peut-être même 23 ans.
Lors de notre dernière classe, je vous ai demandé
s'il y avait quoi que ce soit que vous vouliez.
Le seul souhait que vous ayez exprimé,
la seule chose que vous m'ayez demandée,
durant tous ces mois que nous avons passés ensemble,
était que je vous parle en coréen.
Juste une fois.
J'étais là pour vous apprendre l'anglais ;
vous saviez que c'était interdit.
Mais j'ai compris, vous vouliez partager ce lien avec notre langue maternelle.
Je vous appelais mes gentlemen,
mais je ne sais pas si la gentillesse
dans la Corée du Nord sans pitié de Kim Jong-Un
est une bonne chose.
Je ne veux pas que vous meniez une révolution —
laissez une autre jeune personne le faire.
Le reste du monde pourrait, en passant, encourager ou même attendre
un genre de Printemps nord-coréen,
mais je ne veux pas que vous fassiez quoi que ce soit de risqué,
parce que je sais que dans votre monde, quelqu'un observe toujours.
Je ne veux pas imaginer ce qui pourrait vous arriver.
Si mes efforts pour vous atteindre ont inspiré quelque chose de nouveau en vous,
je préférerais que vous m'oubliez.
Devenez des soldats de votre Grand Leader, et vivez de longues vies, en sécurité.
Vous m'avez une fois demandée si je trouvais votre ville, Pyongyang, jolie,
et je n'ai pas pu vous répondre franchement.
Je sais pourquoi vous m'avez demandé.
Je sais que c'était important pour vous de m'entendre, moi, votre professeure,
celle qui a vu le monde qui vous est interdit,
déclarer votre ville comme étant la plus belle.
Je sais qu'entendre ceci rendrait vos vies là-bas un peu plus supportables,
mais non, je ne trouve pas votre capitale jolie.
Pas parce qu'elle est monotone et en béton,
mais à cause de ce qu'elle symbolise :
un monstre qui se nourrit du reste du pays,
où les citoyens sont des soldats et des esclaves.
Tout ce que j'y vois est l'obscurité.
Mais c'est votre maison, alors je ne peux la haïr.
Et j'espère à la place que vous, mes gentils jeunes gentlemen,
aideront un jour à la rendre belle.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)